[Music]
hello
everybody um Dr Bashar V from the
University of Notre Dame uh I'm a
professor in the department of chemical
and biomolecular Engineering I'll be
talking about antibody
purification using an unconventional
nucleotide binding site
now the sneak to binding side is not
well known and uh although despite the
discovery that was in 1996 with a
publication in
pnas uh it hadn't been well
characterized and so when I started out
as an assistant professor uh 15 years
ago uh the first thing I did was to uh
investigate whether or not this Pockets
really
existed well so it's described to be on
the variable region on the Fab as you
can see in this box on the left side
this is an IGG uh the green is the light
chain the blue is the uh the heavy chain
the dark green and the dark blue region
is where the variable domain is but as
everybody knows by now the um the pocket
is not entitle or the the the uh
variable region is not entirely variable
the really the variable region is the
hyper variable the which is made out of
the six complementary to determining uh
region Loops these six Loops three on
the heavy chain three on the light chain
shown in this uh Crystal uh structure
overlay on the very top of the graph
where you see the uh
Mis aligned sequences on top of each
other is where the antigen binding site
is where the complimentary to
determining region is the rest of the
sequences align particularly well
because those are actually actually
framework regions although it is part of
the variable domain they're not variable
and they're conserved and so what we did
was we took about at the time there were
260 uh something antibody Crystal
structures available in the protein Data
Bank we took them all we superimposed
those structures I'm only showing 16 or
so of them here um and we looked at if
there were conserved you know sequences
residues and made up of Pockets that
made up a pocket on the side of
the the Fab region and what we found out
was that which is shown here with the
side chains conserved three tyrosine and
a chopan residue that make up this
pocket uh on the side as uh defined to
be called the nucleotide binding site
now different colors the green is uh
indicate different ISO types of
antibodies the green is IGG the purple
is IG and uh the Orange is
IGM these antibodies are from various
different species so human rats you know
uh rabbits uh all sorts of uh you know
horses all sorts of different antibodies
uh originating from different
species and these residues that make up
that binding site are conserved not just
between isotypes of antibodies but also
through species as well
and not only these residues conserved at
those specific locations but their side
chain confirmations were also conserved
so the next thing that we did was to uh
take these Crystal structures and start
looking at small molecule libraries and
doing docking uh studies using in silico
approaches what we found out was that uh
we found multiple different sequences uh
you know small molecules that fitted
into that pockets and they aligned
itself in this particular case um
showing how indol tribut acid or IBA
fits into this pockets and aligns itself
uh with the trp Defan sidechain indol
and uh through the pi pie stacking it uh
is making favorable
interactions we determined The Binding
Affinity uh to be ranging somewhere
between one and8
micromolar uh the KD and that is not
because the pockets really varied but it
was because of constrictions at the lip
of the pocket that prevented the
entrance of the molecules into that
site and so but the the the off rate
would be the same which is which is if
what is affected is the on rate
constant now we evaluated and uh
developed multiple different
Technologies around this pocket and uh
you know uses thereof including antibody
uh purification which I'll be describing
but we've also developed methods around
Sight specific conjugation as well as an
uh allergy inhibitor that we used um use
this pocket for a heterobivalent
inhibitor design that uh the inhibitor
that sits in the antigen binding site
its binding is improved and the efficacy
of inhibition is improved by making the
molecule by veent through conjugation to
um a nucleotide in site targeting liant
in this antibody purification uh
application we have two different
methods that we have developed but I'll
I'll first focus on the resin
application the idea is pretty simple we
mobilize the nucleotide binding site uh
targeting ligans on resins um just like
with any other effiny purification
method the antibody will be captured
through its interaction of its
nucleotide binding size and you know
keep in mind that an intact antibody uh
an IGG is going to have two active
nucleotide binding sites so they will be
very effectively captured and all the
contaminants or misfolded or monovalent
antibodies will just elud
through so the column is uh as you can
see this is a very you know small column
uh that we made multiple different
resins and packed into this column and
the idea is to um
use the column to capture the antibodies
and elude everything else so the
chromatogram that you see at the bottom
is uh the impurities just elude because
they're not captured as soon as the
injection is done you know the void
volume comes out at two and a half three
minutes and uh by changing the buffer
running buffer to illusion buffer we're
able to get out the pure end but is a
single clean
Peak the two buffers that we use for
this process uh the first one is
equilibration buffer or the capture
buffer it has 100 m sodium phosphate and
3 Millar I'm sorry three molar sodium
chloride at neutral pH the illusion
buffer doesn't have the sodium chloride
uh the change in the ionic strength of
the buffer is what's uh yielding the
illusion of the antibody it's the the
The Binding of the uh Lian to this
pocket is through hydrophobic
interactions and increas in salt uh
increases the Affinity of the liant to
the antibody when the salt is removed
the antibody is eluded and the resin is
a well is aminol link uh resin from
thermofisher it's basically an agarose
based uh Amin reactive uh resin so we uh
took this resin and then modified the
surface accordingly and when we make
this using the nucleotide binding site
Li to the column uh it costs about $100
per gram of resin um when we purchase
the the resin from thermal Fisher but
equivalent you know protein a column
costs 14 times as
much all right so the first injections
uh that we've done on this column was to
prove that it's uh able to capture
antibodies and so we started working
with pure antibodies like the devasis
and rukab and in both both cases you see
that uh increased volumes with a
constant uh concentration of each one of
those antibodies um is uh well basically
resulting a increase in the height of
the uh illusion Peak where the antibody
is eluding out and it's just showing a
very efficient uh capture of these
antibodies in each
case the uh injection concentration is
also evaluated in the earlier uh slide I
showed the concentration was constant we
increased the volume of injection and
this one uh we kept the volume constant
but we increased the
concentration uh it it each injection up
to 3 micromolar concentration of basum
up and they're able to um capture still
capture and retain the uh antibody on
the resin until we use the ution buffer
uh I'm showing the increased
concentrations for ruk map and the
chromatograms on the right uh the you
know overlay chromatograms be up and
reduc them upap are at the maximum
concentration that we evaluated them at
300 micromolar
um 200 microl injection the effect of
injection
concentration um again you know if you
look at the capture efficiency what we
see is that even at 300 micromolar
concentration we are able to capture
over
99% of the antibody on the
column now the characterization of the
uh need to that binding side column we
wanted to make sure that the illusion
was not some other for you know
foreseeable effect and to evaluate that
we changed the um the gradients a little
bit where we started the illusion first
start uh running say you know like five
minutes first then and then after 12.5
minutes of injection and then after 20
minutes of injection and in each case
you can see that the illusion buffer was
the driving force to uh push the
antibody out of the column
and the flow rate was also of course in
effect as you can see here as we slow
down the flow rate of the um the solvent
through the column the illusion of the
antibody uh was delayed so at the
fastest rate that we were running this
column at 7 Ms per minute the antibody
eludes are around 9 minutes or so um but
as we slow down the uh flow rate the
antibody is and you know it's
eludes later of course also because of
the slow uh you know flow the Peaks also
get broadened out as
expected um the salt effect of salt in
the original uh sample that injected on
the column was evaluated is you know I
mentioned earlier
we use salt to capture the antibody so
increased salt concentration and the
buffer that the antibody is uh present
doesn't really negatively affect the
antibody or the column's ability to
capture the antibod so um zero molar
sodium chloride in the sample buffer
where the you know the antibody was kept
before injection or versus three molar
didn't really make any uh significant
changes in the ability to C capture the
antibody and lastly we evaluated the
effect of uh pH uh of the illusion
buffer on the antibody and what we saw
was that the uh decreased pH you know
increased acidity had a negative effect
negative impact of on our ability to
capture this antibody probably due to uh
the antibod starting to misfold and lose
its uh structure and you know stick to
the column or the resin um more
drastically um if we have salt in the
equilibration buffer as expected the
capture efficiency is
reduced um
and right I'm sorry I meant the other
way around if if the salt in the ution
buffer is high at three molar sodium
chloride the capture efficiency is
really high if the reduced to Salt
concentration the capture efficiency is
sacrificed and beas suuma was perhaps
was still effectively captured at two
molar sodium chloride but for
trastuzamab at two molar sodium chloride
we were already uh losing part of the
antibody and we're unable to capture
100% of the antibody unfortunately and
you if you look at this uh results here
for different antibodies we have
slightly different capture efficiencies
weap and beap with three molar sodium
chloride we have 99% uh capture
efficiency typically with lowered salt
concentrations the antibody capture
efficiency is reduced um but for
antibodies like tmap and M Millis map
you can see that this efficiency is is
even more drastically effective and BSA
is a control uh
here now yeah be here's the uh same
chart again be zoom up chromatogram is
shown on the
left now the specificity of the uh
interaction so to test this uh we
replace the nucleotide binding site
liant with
Glycine and it did the injections as you
can see on the right the BSA of course
doesn't get uh captured um but likewise
basab or rap are not captured on this
control columns
either if uh the nuclein side Lian is
replaced with uh the glycine showing
that the nucle binding side Lian is
necessary now when it comes to the
universal applicability of the uh
antibody purification these columns did
not perform um the same for all
antibodies and what you can see is that
we have a few different lians for a few
different you know uh columns that we
generated and it's not only that but
it's also the loading density of the
ligant on the resin uh makes a
difference in in terms of the column's
ability to capture and retain these
antibodies and what comes down to it is
that uh individual KD individual
monovalent Affinity of the liand to the
antibody and for uh some antibodies the
same liant has um well can have a range
of an order of magnitude Affinity um
depending on whether or not that
nucleotide binding site is easily
accessible
or if there are residues at the lip of
that structure preventing The nucle
Binding side Lian having easy access to
that binding pocket now if you look at
the results the control in any one of
those examples on the you know the table
on the right uh none of these antibodies
were really captured at any any good
efficiency the MBS liant 2 in this table
uh was good for for some antibodies but
uh not all of those and was nucleotide
binding side Lian 4 and like I mentioned
we have multiple different lians that we
have used and you know we can always
find a ligan that works well for you
know multiple different antibodies but
not so great for some others and uh if
we take a sample of the antibody that we
want to purify and run a few injections
on different colums we can identify the
reasin that will work the best for that
antibody
the bo serum albumin challenge is to
show that the column doesn't capture the
BSA and in this case we have a column we
have inject we have injections of BSA at
increasing concentrations uh none of
which is captured and all the BSA comes
out at the you know the void volume and
when we mix it with something like B
suab at 10 micromolar which is a 60 fold
you know difference in uh
concentration at the highest BSA
concentration the B basuma Peak appears
tiny in comparison to BSA that's why
it's uh it's hard to see the basum up uh
Peak but it is actually the same
intensity as the earlier columns that we
have shown so what we do is we collect
these after the injections and then we
investigate it flow through right the
void volume uh Peak to the illusion Peak
and at these different concentrations
you can see that the BSA uh
contaminating into the illusion uh Peak
is at very low concentrations and the
the um the light chain and the heavy
chain of the antibody are labeled on the
uh the gel on the right and perhaps it
if you have such high contamination with
the BSA a second injection would be um
necessary to purify it
further and uh likewise ruk map is also
captured through and what we're showing
here is the um the ability of the
antibody to capture these the the
ability of the column to capture these
antibodies with such high concentrations
of
contaminants and yes there is a
reduction in our ability to capture the
antiv if the contaminant uh
concentration is so high unsurprisingly
especially with something like Alin
which is very sticky probably you know
sticking to the surface of the resin
preventing The nucleotype Binding side
lean to intract uh with the
antibodies hence um the the uh
efficiency of pu purification is reduced
to 91 and to
92% for basuma
and in comparison to uh when the
contaminant concentration is not as High
um which was closer to
99% times and then we wanted to see if
the impurities or the kind of impurities
really made a difference in um the
column's ability to purify anything and
so we challenged the column with aides
at different concentrations and
transfering and uh cell lates
conditioned media cell condition media
with two different cell lines with
multiple my cell line and a Varian
cancer cell line and um in any one of
these case we didn't see the column
capturing uh
impurities uh from anything um anything
else and the uh all the uh all the
contaminant came out in the earlier Peak
all right and the colum usability was
something else that we evaluated and
after three over 300 injections uh the
column was robust uh the the nuclear
that binding side liant does not elute
or leech off of the resin so uh un likee
you know protein a or protein G columns
uh this column is pretty much
indestructible and you just put it in
20% ethanol and keep it in the fridge
and it will last
forever all right now I'm going to uh
shift gears just a little bit and tell
you a little bit more about uh another
project that has been going on in the
lab instead of using resin in this
particular case we uh we're using
membranes so what we do is we take the
membrane and then we functionalize the
membrane again using um our nucleotide
binding side lians and uh Capt use
multiple of these uh membranes lay them
on top of each other and uh well
sandwich them in between these two frits
and uh put them on a spin column you
know application use them in a spin
column application where you where you
take an endorf put the uh you know spin
column inside the endorf you we first
wash the column using the uh the
equilibration buffer just spin it wash
the resin uh I mean the membrane and
then we add in the sample that has
contaminants in it uses Cal Force to
push the liquid through antibody gets
captured on the membrane contaminants go
through and then we use um another drop
of you know a cration buffer uh to wash
off the contaminants that may be still
in the fritz or the membranes and then
in the next step we use the illusion
buffer and um you know just get the an
but it's out of the captured you know
membranes and at the bottom of the
tube so uh here we show that the
monocolonal antibody um in the case of
no membranes just goes through the fritz
immediately and if the membranes are not
functionalized again all these
antibodies that we have on the right we
tested uh you know variety of different
antibodies I believe there are eight of
them here none of them were captured
basically and whatever you see in the
you know equilibration buffer in the
second step or the illusion buffers is
the things that are you know minuscule
amounts that were left in the frit uh in
the pores Etc none of them were
effectively
captured so what we do is we take um a
membrane right and we using carox we
generate a carboxilic acid
functionalization on the surface of the
membrane and then using typically an
amid uh coupling we would just go ahead
and couple uh and functionalize these
memories and by the way these membranes
are typically SOS
membranes and uh then here is you know
what what changes is the number of
membranes that we use to pack on top of
each other which will affect the binding
capacity um and we're investigating
things like uh how much can we capture
what's the retention rate and is it
universally applicable and you know is
in the case where we the we were
modifying the resonance it wasn't
universally applicable but we had a few
different resins that we would be
suitable for a variety of different
antibodies but we didn't have one resin
that worked for
everything um so we wanted to
investigate if that was true for uh this
membrane uh columns the pin columns as
well but um for our luck it turned out
to be much more you know broadly
applicable so you can see that the um
original uh samples you know the the so
so there are five um you know different
regions that we show in this graph the
first one is when you load the sample uh
wash it through there isn't much
antibody left in it because you know we
captured most of it we do a wash with
the equilibration buffer uh there isn't
much antibody in that one either when we
do the illusion buffer uh illusion
buffer one we capture most of the
antibody when we repeat the process to
wash off uh any un eluded antibodies
there's again not much antibod so single
uh application of the spin column is
very successful in uh purifying all
these eight different
antibodies and uh here are the
recoveries they're always in the you
know 90 to 95% range uh successful
recovery and it's not just that
antibodies are not just captured as you
know molecules we want to make sure that
these antibodies that we captured are
still functional are able to B to their
antigens and so we use tresters map and
uh using flow
cytometry um using breast cancer the
skbr3 cell lines we were able to uh bind
and label these breast cancer cell line
U is trus map is an anti herto receptor
binding
antibody and uh you know when we compare
the nuclear binding side you know
membranes to protein a membranes the
purities that we you know manage to get
out of these spin columns are very com
comparable you can see that uh there
when there's no contaminant when we
contaminate the samples with BSA aides
or uh the chw cell uh conditioned media
if you compare the gels on the left and
the right you will see that the purities
of the antibodies between purified using
our uh NBS spin columns versus the
protein a spin columns are very
comparable and we're getting similar
efficiencies in
purities as uh summarized here the whole
cell DNA and whole cell protein um you
know contaminants in either one of those
are also negligible and comparable to
prot
so I want to wrap up here um what I've
shown here is that you know we
identified a small well a few different
small molecules that we use to Target
The nucleo Binding site uh for fast
simple and efficient antibody
purification we typically get over you
know 90% recovery of these antibodies
they're active they're also Bently
active it's not just one of the arms but
typically you need to have both of the
arms to be active so that in The nucle
Binding site lians um work with multi
veency and the efficiency of the capture
is much more um you know
consistent and the illusion conditions
are gentle the captured antibodies
retain their activity for their
antigens and um the cost is
significantly lost compared to protein A
and G uh applications The Columns are
easy to maintain uh they're you know
practically indestructible
and um yeah uh we're very confident in
moving these forward for uh more
hopefully uh industrial
applications and with that uh I would
like to thank all our funding agencies
and um all the students graduate
students who did the work most of this
work was done during the pandemic so
that's why they're in this picture
they're wearing their masks um and then
several of them have graduated now and
moved on to uh industrial positions and
with that thank you for your attention
um